Ngày 2 tận chiến 5 in chính trăm 1 mi làm tại khoảng trường và định lịch sử giọt nói của chủ tịch hồ chính mình vang lên chăm phục mặt thà thiết
Từ bay định 5 ấy, những lời mất khu vẫn quan phọng đi hôm nay,
khi một bản chương cá về khách phọng độc lập, tự gió và hạnh phúc của muốn đời xin tộc.
Nó không chỉ là lời tuyên bố với độc bào mà còn là lời khẳng định với khoảng thế giới,
về quyền bất khả xin phạm của xin tộc Việt Nam.
Mình mặt đình bạm của kai, bây giờ vui vui vình tộc già độc là đầy.
Bất chi trận những cái văn đặc, có chỉ chấp trăm kiện của người khác.
Mình khi văn đặc mấy rất là tính bộ.
Thì bác quý nhắc là 2 cái nếu pháp và đất bý,
là tôi chỉ trận của anh, là tôi đầm với khách phòng điểm của anh,
thì anh phải thực hiện cái người anh hỏi,
cái nè viết cái người anh, thì anh phải thực hiện.
Vì vậy đó, của anh cũng nhắc nhỏ 2 của bố chức đất bếng là mình chỉ tựa đặc pháp,
hại thực hiện cái việc mà công nhận các quyền dân tộc của khác về tật khác.
Chẳng đỏ, có nước, đường nào, tình chủ của khác, người bây giờ thì có đầy mà thái xác hạnh,
và rất là khôn hoa.
Tuyên 1 đặc lập của chủ tịch khổ chỉ mình có giá trị phó lớn,
cả về lịch sử pháp liếp và tư tường.
Dựa trên các nguyên liếp tiến bộ của ninh loại,
để khẳng định quyền sống, quyền tự ra và quyền mừng câu hạnh phúc của mỗi xin tộc.
Thế hiện sự thống nhất giữ quyền nục lập xin tộc và quyền tự ra của con người.
Thế hiện phát phọng phà bình, tình thần glàn ghét và ý chiến kinh tường bảo vệ lập xin tộc bằng mọi giá.
Bản quyền 1 đã đánh giấu móc, chấm rất ec lâu hộ của thức xanh,
không kiến, mở giác kiến nguyên nục lập, tự ra cho xin tộc Việt Nam.
Hẳng định trước quốc xanh và thị dưới, sự sau đời của nước Việt Nam sẽ chủ cộng hoa.
Năm tháng trôi qua, nhưng tình thần của bản quyền 1 lập lập vẫn chường tổng trái tiêm vào khi hệ người viện.
Những tự tưởng trong bản quyền 1 vẫn vệ miệng giá chị cho của thành quan cầu Việt này,
để cao quyền con người, quyền tự nguyết của các xanh tộc,
khu khách vọng sống trong phà bình, trong bằng phản giến ái, những giá chị ấy tiếp tục xanh tộc dường,
giảm giát xanh tộc Việt Nam trên thành chiến sự nước và sự nước hôm nay.